bonjour parce qu'elle serait merci de
répondre à nos questions emmanuel macron
a estimé que le vaccin astrazeneca est
recommandée et doit être utilisé dans le
même temps la haute autorité de santé on
vient de le voir recommande d'injecter
au 533 mille français concernés qui ont
eu ces vaccins plomb ajaccio à d'avoir
une deuxième dose de vaccin arn messager
c'est le cas de faille the one tech ou
encore de modern art il ya de quoi semer
le trouble le français lambdas hyper
vous qu'est ce que vous dites à vos
patients
alors concrètement on est perplexe que
ce soit la population que ce soit les
médecins
on nous annonce des choses complètement
contradictoire entre l'achat laisse l'om
s j'avoue que je sais plus quoi dire à
mes patients je leur dis que je peux
leur proposer le vaccin astrazeneca s'il
souhaite le faire aux lf s ils veulent
pas le faire on ne fait pas j'avoue
qu'on a un manque de communication
claire là dessus et les gens plus
confiance et c'est vraiment très
compliqué en une situation qui est
extrêmement complexe et on n'a pas
d'outils pour donner des réponses
claires aux patients votre sujet avant
le montre bien le ms pour eux il n'ya
pas d'étude suffisamment de l'adéquation
entre l'effet de faire deux vaccins
différents ou un sound
en angleterre ils font deux fois le même
il n'y a pas de problème quoi
hier dans cette édition il y avait jean
paul stahl en invité infectiologues au
chu de grenoble
il disait qu'il n'y avait pas de danger
associé deux vaccins à technologie
différente
ici c'est le cas en l'occurrence un
vaccin vecteur viral pour astrazeneca
arènes messager pour fire biotech
moderna même son de cloche de jean
daniel lelièvre qu'on a vu d'ailleurs
dans le sujet d'un média soubelet il est
expert à la haute autorité de santé donc
pas de danger pour eux mais dans deux
côtés vous venez de dire le ms et qui
dit ne pas avoir de données adéquates
sur l'interchangeabilité des des vaccins
et donc au final
qui croire alors il ya deux problèmes
déjà le problème c'est de compatibilité
des vaccins entre eux cela on le sait il
ya aucun problème
ça fait depuis pasteur depuis la
multiplication des vaccins on sait très
bien que les vaccins peuvent se faire
tous en même temps y'a pas de problème
par contre qu'est ce qu'il en est de
l'efficacité on nous parle du vaccin
contre le vih
or à preuve du contraire verser 1 contre
le vih il expérimental on nous parle de
technique de prix et de prime boosting
d'immunité voilà on est expérimental
on ne sait pas est ce qu'on peut se
permettre d'être expérimental avec une
épidémie de kobe dans france qui flambe
avec des nombres de cas explosif avec
des antilles en réanimation explosive
est-ce qu'on tousse permettent d'être
expérimental on ne sait pas quelle est
l'efficacité de ces vaccins chaque
vaccin a pris séparément et efficace
avec une efficacité qui ralentit au bout
d'un certain nombre de semaines ou de
mois qui impose une deuxième injection
donc pour l'astra zeneca le kaiser et le
modern art mais on ne sait pas quelle
est l'efficacité au long terme de deux
vaccins différents injecté là moi je
veux des réponses précises clair là
dessus et j'en ai pas outre le vaccin
d'astrazeneca celui de johnson & johnson
est également visé par une enquête là
aussi vous êtes inquiet alors on est
inquiets vis-à-vis du risque
thromboembolique après moi je me pose
quand même une question on sait que la
maladie qu'ovide provoque des troubles
thromboemboliques je crois qu'il ya
entre un patient sur cinq et un patient
sur quatre en réanimation qui a une
embolie pulmonaire ou une phlébite
donc ça veut dire que la maladie
elle-même génère des troubles
thromboemboliques donc il est tout à
fait logique que le vaccin
visant à humaniser cette maladie puisse
déclencher des trous trop mort relique
après à l'heure actuelle au niveau
mondial j'ai ressorti des chiffres ce
matin on est à moins de 100 cas de
maladie thromboembolique sur 25 millions
de doses
c'est pas c'est une personne sur deux
c'est 115 sur 25 millions le risque il
est faible il suffit de faire un premier
tri au départ des patients ceux qui sont
trop à risque
on leur fait pas et ceux qui ne sont pas
et c'est qu'il souhaite le faire on leur
fait pourtant on a l'impression que le
mal est fait en termes peut-être de
communication en tous les cas il ya une
grosse défaillance dans la population
d'un côté on apprend un nouveau retard
de livraison d'astrazeneca prévues cette
semaine pour l'union européenne de
l'autre côté on l'a vu sur sur les
images à emmanuel macron a visité hier
une usine delpharm qui commence à
embouteiller les doses de vaccin à
pfizer
entre retards de production et lenteur
initiale de la campagne vaccinale à
l'accélération de celles ci on s'y perd
un peu et puis on aperçoit également ce
sondage qu'on aperçoit à côté de vous
64% des français selon une étude doxa
d'ansu consulting pour france info et le
figaro paru cette semaine
eh bien on ne croit pas aux annonces des
manuels macron vous est ce que vous y
croyez
depuis le début de la campagne de
vaccination on ne voit que retards de
livraison que ce soit des livraisons
pour les centres de vaccination là je
viens d'apprendre que la fameuse
accélération des vaccinations ans entre
pfizer et modern à l'augmentation des
livraisons programmées c'est pour juin
c'est pas pour avril mais nous les doses
astrazeneca pour le cabinet avant qu'ils
aient ce problème de défiance
on a mis un mois pour avoir nos doses
supplémentaires et donc voir le maximum
de personnes vaccinées je ne vois pas le
planning gouvernementale respecter pour
qu'on ait une nuitée collectif c'est 80%
justement par du planning
gouvernementale il ya même un planning
européen puisque le commissaire européen
tiré au breton lui il a dit hier
l'objectif de l'immunité collective à
70% à la mi juillet en france et je cite
atteignable franchement c'est pour moi
et ma vie personnelle mais j'y crois pas
on déjà bien falloir que les gens
acceptent de faire vacciner est là avec
toutes ces histoires
les gens ont beaucoup n'ont plus envie
c'est leur droit
les endroits pas se faire vacciner mes
limites et collectives à 70% les
dernières études les dernières
publications font plus tôt et 4 80% pour
la limite est suffisante
merci parce qu'elle serait d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste en saône
et loire